night fliers you crazy son-of-a-bitch
shoo you did it you broke me Oh son of a
[ __ ] I was planning to do an ending
explain video for you but then you had
to do this to me yes for those of you
who've been around my channel for a
while you've probably seen some of my
night Flyers videos pop up and in all
honesty I thought this show had
something going for it the first few
episodes although not perfect were fun
and promising but things started to take
a turn it's like have you ever met
someone and they seemed kind of cool and
you enjoy spending time with them then
all of a sudden they do like one weird
thing and you kind of brush it off and
try to forget about it but then a few
days later they do something even
weirder until you're invested too deep
and realize you're dating Gary Busey
that's night fliers so what I want to do
here is dissect this mess so that george
RR martin can go back to doing god's
work night fliers is essentially the
tale of a crew being sent out to make
contact with an alien force the valle
Crenn in the hopes that it may hold the
key to save Earth which is dying that's
the basic premise of the show I think
it's pretty cool I just wish the writers
mm-hmm didn't forget about it you see
the most compelling aspect of this
premise is the save humanity part those
are the stakes it's what's gonna keep me
invested yet almost every character in
the show at one point or another puts
their own self-interests ahead of all of
humanity arguably the biggest threat to
this mission is the AI Cynthia and what
does the second-in-command Auggie do
smashes the crystal which would have
trapped her for good because love I
guess mommy lets young Cynthia live even
though she's just an AI and that totally
backfires Rowan tries to break the
decontamination chamber which would kill
everyone on board
Agatha comes on the ship even though she
knows that two L's in close proximity
with one another can cause serious
problems carl cares more about spending
time with his daughter in the memory
sphere than helping the freaking captain
of the ship who could die at any moment
it's as if every character has forgotten
why they're here forgotten about the
billions of humans back home who are
counting on them but let's get down into
the nitty
shall we and pick apart some of the
things that make absolutely no sense
turning what could have been a great
series into a pile of space garbage from
its inception night fliers was billed as
a psychological horror in space but it's
not really a horror at all at least for
the first few episodes there was some
mystery behind the visions and who
exactly is controlling the ship leaves
us with a bit of suspense but once
Cynthia's revealed as the source all
that tension evaporates take the scene
where Karl sees his dead daughter in the
corridor should be scary right oh yeah
if it weren't for Rowan right behind him
saying oh don't worry about that she's
just a harmless vision where's the
horror in that with the exception of
perhaps the Thanos dissolving baby
there's really no horror after that and
let me tell you that baby is problematic
we'll get to that in a bit next point
big character reveals are almost
completely glossed over Roy is a robot
no one cares Agatha is an L so what Mel
finds the person responsible for genetic
mutation yawn what I'm getting at here
is these revelations have huge
psychological and emotional ripples that
will affect how the characters will
interact with one another and the
choices they will make both as
individuals and as a team yet these big
reveals are glossed over insanely
quickly oh and is it just me or did Carl
get over the fact a Geetha had a baby
with him really quickly and it's never
even brought up again even more
frustrating is how night fliers takes
common tropes and rather than make them
new or provide a fresh take they become
derivative here's a quick list red crazy
AI like Hal and 2001 a Space Odyssey the
crazy ax murder like The Shining or
perhaps you prefer the sci-fi version
sunshine Eden robot mysteriously working
for her company
alien seeing visions in a sphere contact
weird organic stuff with teeth in it
David Cronenberg's existence someone
warning people to get out get out there
are even a bunch of plot points that are
just simply dropped like Agatha and
Karl's baby Joy's response to Carl's
divorce the probe containing Carl's DNA
how can she control the bees where can I
get the best space hot dog and are we
just going to forget that
eight months past now I understand we
need to show the passing of time as we
get closer to the vole Crenn but it felt
like the real reason for this time lapse
was just a show testes baby too
integrate and the baby thing leaves
unanswered questions - how did it
manifest itself like that how come no
one else was affected and if it was the
Vall Curran how come people like Harlan
Rowan who actually touched pieces of it
didn't get infected why would the Vulcan
do this what is its purpose
none of these are answered in an all
seem like an extremely convoluted way to
get Rowan to go mad but hey we gotta
cool this integrating baby this is also
a world where you can make 3d printed
food career third-degree burns in a few
days genetically tailored DNA and yet
everything has to be manually overridden
and the brilliant plan to get into
Eris's cabin is to steal poop manually
from a pipe yeah that happened not to
mention the ship has a function where
you can just simply blow up part of it
why why is that a thing
that's a serious hazard if say someone
were to go crazy in love with an AI
why does Rowan go mad after the death of
his child
millions of people lose loved ones every
year and they don't go on murdering
sprees Carl didn't after Agatha was it
the teak energy that made him do it if
so how come this wasn't telegraphed
earlier on and building him up with say
bleeding eyes or visions and then at the
end he's like back to his normal self
again even more insane as Carl recruits
him because look how this is a guy who
just went on a killing spree and all
he's done with the Volk run is probe it
with some tongs and run a few DNA tests
why is Roy's robot body back in his room
the ship is literally getting destroyed
and someone's like I should take this
robot back to get some rest there's no
one else care their captain was a robot
this entire time and why isn't Mel like
WTF you were a robot like if I were her
I'd have so many questions so many
questions is it just me or for the last
three episodes la me just kind of chills
in the pipes by herself the one person
who can manipulate and control the
entire ship through her body and she's
like barely checked up on if Cynthia
could just transfer her consciousness
into a real body like she did with mommy
then why not do that since the very
beginning seems a lot more convenient
and she could probably do a lot more
damage there were at least a half dozen
or more scenes where there are big
catastrophic things happening to the
ship and some of them have scared extras
running around while others have none
it makes it seem like some days they
couldn't afford extras and are we really
to believe that on this entire ship
there's only one escape pod that
literally holds just one person this is
like the Titanic of spacecrafts fail
whose powers are insane right now who
can tell Carl where to go telepathically
jump out of his own body and communicate
with an alien being can't tell Carl he's
about to get whacked in the back of the
head Mel is touted as being this
genetically superior being but seriously
how does this affect the story other
than that one scene where she can
withstand the radiation longer even
though Roy could have fixed it himself
since he's a robot but then later on we
see Auggie and Murph just chilling in
there no problem did the radiation
disappear and finally my biggest
complaint there's no ending we spend 10
episodes with these characters and we
just leave them no closure with maybe
the exception of Carl but even that is
ambiguous and open to interpretation and
don't get me wrong open / ambiguous
endings are fine that is if they have
something they're trying to say a bigger
thematic question to leave the audience
pondering like the most great Syfy's do
but night fliers didn't give us that
instead we got masturbating cannibal
women thanks for watching everyone I
hope you'll give this video a like share
and all that fun stuff I've got more
videos plans so make sure you're
subscribed to get all the latest things
story videos and remember daddy loves
you very much
[Music]